[Musique]
au québec on aime la pomme chaque
automne pour certaines familles c'est le
rituel de la cueillette pour la déguster
bien frais les méthodes de conservation
de permettre maintenant de la croquer
alan gross évolution à descendre tout
était fini au niveau de la pomiculture
maintenant on est capable d'offrir la
pomme 12 mois par année compétitionner
les marchés amérique du sud des états
unis
on est capable d'avoir des femmes
québécoises à calais à longueur d'année
et à partir du moment de la récolte vont
être posées sont mis dans des chambres
atmosphère modifiée on les endort on
retire un petit tour le jeune qu'on
remplace par des naseaux et on contrôle
la maturité des pandas ses champs bleus
au verger paul jodoin ont produit les
jus tradition appartiennent
exclusivement de pommes du québec
[Musique]
un des produits les plus difficiles les
plus fragiles à travailler c'est la
pomme il ya la maturité de la pomme et
les variétés pour faire le mélange de
différents facteurs qui fait qu' on doit
constamment ajuster les mélanges et
jules kouassi d'avoir un jus stable
parce qu on braille ses gammes de ce
même père ça pour ça nos jeux sont
passés au nom des conditions sous
diverses formes ont fait des jurés qui
gérait frais ont fait gagner des jeux
naturel on peut entreposer température
pièces allant ouverture et on fait des
jeux pitié si tradition plutôt offrir
des jus fait exclusivement avec la pomme
québécoise il n'en va pas de même pour
les autres transformateurs
au québec les pomiculteurs récolte en
moyenne chaque année 100 mille tonnes de
pommes
ce qui est très peu en comparaison avec
la chine qui en produit 44 millions de
tonnes sur une production mondiale
totale de 75 millions
d'année en année on prend toutes les
bonnes qui ne sont amenés dans nos
différents sites de la majorité au
québec ainsi qu'en nouvelle écosse est
aussi en montagne chez lassonde avec
quatorze usines au canada et aux états
unis et un chiffre d'affaires d'un
milliard et demi de dollars les besoins
en pommes sont immenses contenu que les
pommes qui me sont amenés le court que
10 15% ben on se doit de
s'approvisionner ailleurs dans le monde
dans les grandes régions agricoles
on retrouve les i spécifiquement la
chine l'europe l'amérique du sud et les
états unis pour couvrir nos besoins on
se doit d'aller un peu partout et
acheter des concentrée l'industrie du
concentré pam en chine est quand même
une jeune industrie ça n'existe pas
depuis plus que 20 ans donc de parallèle
à ça c'est que les usines les procédés
les façons de faire ont tous été
développé en ligne avec les besoins du
marché nord-américain donc des joueurs
comme la sonde comme certains de nos
compétiteurs ont eu leur mot à dire à
savoir comment va-t-il est justement
alors comment fait on pour reconnaître
un produit transformé contenant des
pommes du québec ou du canada s'est
inscrit à l'image du québec temporaire
révélateur c'est des produits d'origine
québécoise confiait ce samedi que sa
grisaille à 85 pour ça y est plus
d'ingrédients d'origine québécoise un
bon choix si je ne marquais aliments
préparés au québec
ça veut dire qu'il ya en dessous de 85 %
d'ingrédients québécois ce qui veut dire
qu'hoarau temps 0% et grézian québécois
que 84 pour ce 6e marqué par contre
produit du canada l'ordre du canada vous
pouvez être certifié qu'elle produit
véritablement du canada emballés ou
préparer au canada qu'est ce que ça nous
dit de la provenance
on parle pas de la provenance des
ingrédients on fait seulement parler de
la dernière transformation qui était
faite qu'il emballages en fait ça fait
seulement dire que ça a été à balai ou
réparés au canada le contenu des
ingrédients on sait pas de vous savez
lorsqu'on voit la mention canada de
choix au canada de fantaisie sur un
produit
qu'est ce que ça signifie si seulement
des normes qui veulent parler du niveau
de sucre de citer notre produit et ce
n'est pas du tout de lien avec le
contenu six québécois ou canadiens
pas du tout et tu peux avoir un produit
canada le choix un jus de pomme fait
avec un jus de pomme et daisy le pollen
des états unis salle indique pas la
provenance
on le voit plus comme un sceau
d'approbation c'est un show pour
s'assurer que consommateurs canadiens
lorsqu'ils achètent un jus pomme canada
de choix
un produit qui répond à nos goûts à nos
standards et voit soudain au pays donc
que ce soit pour un jus une purée ou
même une tarte aux pommes
si vous cherchez un produit content des
pommes d'ici il faut se fie aux
indications aliments du québec ou
produit du canada